i was on a united flight last week  leaving appleton in a hurricane coming  to new york i get on the flight i'm in  28 d i'm in the back of the plane  because i'm a piece of [ __ ] and  this gigantic buff hot french flight  attendant comes up to me and i got  status so i bored first so i'm sitting  there alone in the back of the plane he  goes oh my god i am a fan of we might be  drunk i love the show can i get a photo  and i'm like yeah sure i'm hungover it's  like six in the morning i'm like yeah  yeah the photo's gonna like oh post this  photo sir whatever you're doing this guy  was a hunk  super sexy guy  and uh  i i was sleeping on the plane i passed  out i took a couple pills and passed out  i wake up this guy's got like beers on  my tray  little green hulk little fentanyl but  he's popping beers on the tray because  he's he's like oh you're a drunk you're  you we might be drunk so he's putting  out he's giving me free beer he's loaded  me up